how do you identify an important result
in science and how they died and when
they die recognize that we had done it
this is not easy because in scientific
research you don't know immediately
where if something is correct or not
especially when it's new and unexpected
they big breakthroughs are unexpected
and usually draw a lot of criticism from
others so this is and it may take
several years until buzzers have been
able to repeat the experiments and
confirm that you are right this is
usually the way it goes if the if so
method is shown not to be reproducible
then one is usually in trouble not
always but usually see I was in sports
as I mentioned and there it's very
different I played football you too
you're okay when you kick a goal you are
in the newspaper the next day immediate
there is a media there is not a second
between you having kicked the goal and
do being a hero that's not the way it is
in science there you have typically your
own doubts and then you have the
criticism from outside and sends away
until others have tried to repeat so but
I had the education from sports let's
take high jumping the odds experience of
failing or succeeding in high jumping
it's intense pain instantaneous but it's
also
the experience of what it means to have
reached a certain level of achievement
so when we got the first structure soft
I actually went skiing for two years I
was so sure we had it that I went I went
back to teaching ski I spent two went
two seasons in banging beautiful result
I even meant towns all over horn
racetrack as a photographer well I was
far too old to racing at that time and I
actually went said to write the book
which is still published now it was
published first in 1986 and it's still
on the market and I wrote some papers on
the mechanics of skiing and the nursery
was a large number on our work of the
previous few years and that was fruitful
because it it's a document that made
clear what we had done and that we had
done it first because soon thereafter
the field just exploded and so but I was
sure we had it attacked by jose like I
jumping and I was also sure that nobody
had done anything similar before so at
that point this reasonably well
documented so we had the result in about
focused 1984 and I asked for a
sabbatical hi most out of see th for one
year went to end and started to ski
again I had not skied for 11 years
before i was working i only played
football i bought the house next to a
football stadium so that i put without
loss of time continued to play football
but I never went skiing and so I
news king equipment went to ski school
and took videos to correct small letters
and then I started to teach again as I
had done for many years earlier on I
didn't say where i was going for the
sabbatical when it became known that I
had been skiing they actually changed
rules there is a document which says the
sabbatical is meant to spend time in
university of comparable standing to the
ATR Zurich it is not meant as a vacation
this was a response to by having bit
scary for two months